sustainable energies share and the
production of electricity and Germany
has been growing for years new wind
farms solar and biogas power plants are
being built daily renewables currently
meet about a quarter of germany's energy
demands wind power leads the green
energy sector and has become a key part
of the german economy economists
attribute that to generous subsidies for
producers German consumers cover the
cost of those subsidies in their energy
bills the charge is known as the
renewables levy the more renewable
energy produced the higher the levy
Germany's economics and energy minister
says it's time for that to change yes
first we need to halt a considerable
cost dynamic that's developed in the
renewables levy in recent years second
we have to stabilize things at their
current levels in the coming years and
make sure there are not any future
drastic increases use orbitz it's fun
that led to drastic cuts and subsidies
for wind in the north and solar in the
south the entire sector in particular
producers in the windy northern states
balked at Gabriel's initial plan so that
his reform ended up as a minor
adjustment nevertheless times will get
tougher for producers of renewable
energy and especially bio gas generators
new plant construction is to be held at
100 megawatts annually that's left the
branch troubled we've got investment
consortium that we're about to lose and
private investors who are withdrawing
their capital so the situation is very
tough as soon as SVG laga and dust
Bedoya to test it means that the work of
two decades of intensive development and
innovation with firms from all over the
world will be wrecked with a single
stroke one biggest idiot buddha if
implemented as planned the policy will
cause the death of the german biogas
power plant branch which is currently
number one in the world you know mine
this
valuable energy crops such as wheat or
corn will no longer be available for
power generation instead only manure or
leftover food will be eligible for use
but they produce less power per unit and
are therefore less profitable but
environmental experts say the biogas
cuts are the right thing to do guten be
geothermal and biomass energy did not
meet the expectations that people had
for them that's why the subsidy in the
amended levy is being restricted to very
economical generation methods such as
onshore wind power and solar energy and
for offshore energy which could reduce
energy costs considerably in the coming
years but the government missed the
biggest opportunity to ease the utility
cost burden on private households energy
intensive companies such as steelworks
or German rail will remain exempt from
the renewables levy via other funa given
we're all committed to the shift to
renewables we all want your money to get
on the road to more sustainability and
environmental friendliness without
harming Germany's economic strength in
Midland shaft it's all the way at a
meeting at the chancellor's office there
was a lot of talk about little progress
of invite I'd like to point out that
this of course does not fully address
the issue of the shift to renewables
we're now going to tackle major topics
such as expanding the grid capacity
mechanisms and the way we deal with
producers of conventional power and of
name vid the federal government needs to
regulate the promotion of renewable
energy production in order to limit
uncontrolled growth and electricity
costs so Germany's shift to renewables
will remain a work in progress for some
I